on va se parler aujourd'hui d'erreurs
qui sont courantes qu'on fait lorsqu'on
vient acheter son nouveau smartphone
il arrive un moment où dans notre vie on
doit retrouver notre smartphone alors le
conseil le premier conseil savez de le
garder suffisamment longtemps pour d'une
économiser vous du beau du budget 2 pour
l'empreinte écologique ça sert à rien
changer tout le temps son smartphone
mais quand la question se pose quel
smartphone choisir comment l'acheter
bien on fait tous des erreurs et on se
plante alors aujourd'hui je vous
présente et pas moins de l'unaf erreur
neuf comme ça sur le bout des doigts
qu'on fait tous quand on vient acheter
son smartphone et qui font qu'au final
bien souvent on est déçu on aux
smartphones qui a s'est pas exactement
ça vous avez déjà été déçus lorsque vous
avez acheté un smartphone en rassurez
vous vous n'êtes pas le seul c'est vrai
quand on n'y connaît rien c'est souvent
dur de faire son choix on se laisse
guider par des idées reçues et bien
souvent on est déçu donc ici je vous
dresse la liste non exhaustive des
erreurs courantes communes ont fait tous
lorsqu'on dit à choisir son smartphone
etc on n'y connaît rien l'idée de cette
vidéo c'est de vous présenter les
différentes erreurs pour vous les
fassiez pas la prochaine fois vous avez
changé votre smartphone comme ça vous
serez avertis et y aura plus de problème
et je vous conseille de bien regarder
cette vidéo la fin parce qu'en plus
c'est à dire vous donner quelques
conseils et astuces donc ça c'est super
mais avant toute chose je vous invite à
venir vous abonner pour tout savoir sur
l'actuelle juge patrick mullet
évidemment avec vous tout plein de
conseils d'astuces présente aussi les
nouveautés soient des smartphones des
montres des tablettes et je vous parle
bien évidemment de vous et de votre vie
numérique donc ça c'est super cool vous
invite à cliquer sur le petit bouton en
bas rouges si les rouges c'est que vous
n'êtes pas abonné vous actionnez les
cloches comme ça vous serez identifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera et
ça c'est vraiment bien le premier point
concerne la caméra c'est un des usages
principal on utilise quasiment tous
hormis nos smartphones pour faire des
photos que ce soit pour immortaliser des
moments importants en famille des
vacances des paysages à l'essence d'un
enfant d'un chien compagnie enfin
laissant son chien l'arrivée d'un petit
chien vous ai compris un peu l'histoire
est bien souvent ces savoirs par le
nombre de mégapixels sur une caméra
c'est d'ailleurs un argument marketing
très fort aujourd'hui employé par
beaucoup de marques
on pense façon un peu classique que plus
on donne mégapixels et meilleures seront
les photos c'est pas laisser ses membres
et la qualité vos photos va dépendre de
plusieurs facteurs ce mois dépend déjà
de la qualité de votre capteur ou avoir
un capteur avec 100 8 mégapixels 64
mégapixels 40 ubilla pixels 12
mégapixels et pourtant ne pas voir des
photos qui seront
vraiment à la hauteur salée pendant déjà
de la qualité de votre capteur ça dépend
de la performance d'autres processeurs
si vous avez un processeur qui est
suffisamment puissant pour bien calculer
ça va dépendre de l'intégration
logicielle ça va dépendre des choix
qu'on a fait par le constructeur pour le
rendu final de votre photo ça va
dépendre bien évidemment de votre
optique
vous comprenez ça va dépendre de
beaucoup de facteurs vont regarder par
exemple sur les iphone daniela il faut
être par exemple bannière iphone 12 pro
ou 12 promax c'est aujourd'hui un des
meilleur photophone qui existe et
pourtant vous avez 3 capteur de 12
mégapixels chacun on est donc très loin
des 100 8 mégapixels des quarante huit
mégapixels et pourtant croyez-moi les
photos sont vraiment extrêmement
qualitative et on va même les utiliser
pour tourner des films avec vous voyez
comme quoi c'est pas le nombre qui est
important la deuxième erreur c'est de
vouloir plein de capteurs on se dit
quand on veut acheter un smartphone et
bien on va souvent choisir un smartphone
avec quatre capteurs trois capteurs plus
on en a et plus on se dit que c'est bien
souvent aujourd'hui on nous propose
trois capteurs narnia voix 4 capteur à
l'arrière et puis des fois deux capteurs
à l'avant c'est pas nécessairement le
nombre qui va être une fois de plus
intéressant puisque sur les quatre
capteurs des pouvoirs trouve à l'arrière
eh bien il ya peut-être un seul qui sera
réellement intéressant il arrive dans
des segments sans l'entrée milieu de
gamme devons trouver avec un capteur
principal qu'on va appeler ici le groupe
qui ira bien en tout cas ça sera
probablement le meilleur peuvent
retrouver avec de la macro aujourd'hui
la macro ça sert pas à grand chose peut
retrouver avec deux capteurs profondeur
ça arrive globalement pour me de
portraits ok mais va-t-on souvent
utilisé en mode portrait je suis pas sûr
des fois on a des ultra grand-angle qui
sont pas extraordinaires pas bien
intégrés certain william bell évidemment
mais des fois d'autres non donc ne
regardez pas forcément le nombre de
regarder pas la quantité privilégiez
plutôt la qualité d'où l'intérêt
justement de les regarder des tests pour
savoir si les capteurs sont bien s'ils
sont intéressants d'ailleurs être plus
invite à venir vous abonner comme ça
vous saurez tout pour votre prochain
smartphone mais ça c'est très bien la
troisième erreur c'est souvent de se
baser sur la marque quand on ne connaît
pas on a des a priori sur différentes
marques on dit bah tiens moi je vais
acheter telle marque parce que je la
connais elle est super si par exemple
vous êtes client depuis longtemps chez
samsung
prenons l'exemple et huit mois je vais
acheter un premier samsung parce que je
sais c'est samsung les smartphones sont
bien alors en règle générale c'est bien
il arrive aussi world to qu'à titre
personnel clé des smartphones que je
n'aime pas chez samsung vous en ai déjà
parlé par le passé la plupart du temps
je les aime bien mais défend des trucs
qui vont pas et ce qui est vrai avec
samsung est vrai avec
tous les fabricants ils ont des produits
qui sont très bien réussi il y en a
d'autres
c'est un peu moins c'est surtout le plus
important c'est de trouver le smartphone
callan équation avec vous qui a pouvoir
correspondre à vous bien évidemment mais
surtout à vos usages
effectivement certaines marques vous
rassurer mais n'ayez pas d'à priori
dites vous bien vous allez pouvoir
trouver de très bon smartphone auprès de
marques on ne penserait pas acheter son
smartphone par exemple sur google vous
pouvez trouver un smartphone avec un
seul capteur à l'arrière mais qui
marchera bien mieux que des smartphones
qui ont 4 capteur à l'arrière en termes
de photos qui sera performant qui aura
une bonne expérience qui sera vraiment
agréable à utiliser
autre erreur celle fait de regarder que
la grosse batterie c'est vrai que c'est
un argument marketing est très important
et surtout dans l'entrée de gamme dans
l'autre ils gagnent tous les
constructeurs se battent pour nous
proposer de très grosses batteries 5000
milliampères heures 6000 milles et en
erreur et que ça j'ai encore il y en
aura de plus en plus dans les temps à
venir sera probablement dû 7000 8000
millions période on n'y est pas encore
mais en tout cas c'est la tournure que
ça prend on se dit du coup avec une très
grosse batterie on va profiter d'une
très belle autonomie d'un smartphone qui
va durer extrêmement longtemps alors
c'est vrai est pas vrai à la fois c'est
pas nécessairement vrai puisque
l'autonomie va dépendre bien évidemment
de l'intégration au niveau logiciel va
dépendre surtout de la puissance de
calcul de votre processeur si vous avez
un processeur qui est extrêmement
performant extrêmement puissant il
arrivera donc à tout optimisé et
optimiser bien évidemment il a prolongé
la durée vie de votre batterie
donc ne croyez pas que c'est uniquement
la taille le nombre de milles et
antérieures qui compte c'est
effectivement un indicateur important
mais pas uniquement posée mais surtout
la question du processeur qu'est ce
qu'on va retrouver intérieur est ce que
processeur et performant est ce qu'il ya
de bons résultats une fois de plus me
regarder des tests une grosse erreur
qu'on fait tous c'est de penser fiche
technique avant de penser aux usages la
fiche technique c'est souvent ce qu'on
nous met en avant c'est ce que les
marques mettent en exergue vous avez tel
processeur vous avez telle si vous allez
tel ça vous avez un capteur de 48
mégapixels c'est pas nécessairement
intéressant penser surtout à vous et à
vos usages je vous prends l'exemple du
14 48 mégapixels vous avez différents
fabricants de capteurs 48 mégapixels
vous avez dès qu'ils sont très bons il y
en a d'autres qui sont pas
extraordinaires et qui seront beaucoup
moins performant c'est la même chose
pour les processeurs vous êtes certains
processeurs qui sont très performants
d'autres non dites vous bien que de
toute façon ce que les marques vont
chercher à faire c'est revendre des
produits donc elle va avoir un discours
marketing qui vont aller dans ce sens
pour vous dire on a le meilleur produit
c'est super bien en aura
meilleures photos on aura les meilleures
performances c'est pas nécessairement
vrai une fois de plus venez regarder les
têtes venait comparer et venez vous
renseigner pour vraiment être sûr tout
ça il faut savoir démêler le vrai du
faux par exemple beaucoup de
constructeurs qui vous disent regardez
c'est super vous avez une caméra macro
sur votre smartphone vous pourrez faire
de la macro mais en réalité au niveau
des usages
est-ce que vous allez souvent faire la
macro est-ce que vous avez photographié
des petits insectes à ce que vous aller
photographier votre peau de très près
qu'est ce que vous feriez avec une
caméra de macron moi je suis vraiment
pas convaincu et une fois de plus on va
vous mettre en avant une fiche technique
vous en donner plus
un capteur de plus alors que globalement
tout le monde il existe un très bon
appareil pour faire de la macro mais ça
court pas les rues
vraiment pas si vous achetez un
smartphone et que vous jouez par exemple
et vous joué un fort match n'allait pas
acheter n'importe quel smartphone afin
que force nike puisque tourner dessus
assurez vous que votre processeur sera
suffisamment puissant assurez vous allez
avoir suffisamment drame que en gros
buzz smartphone soit adaptée à vos
usages il la même manière si vous voulez
faire de la vidéo trouvée le smartphone
qui permettra d'avoir un très bon rendu
en vidéo une fois de plus quelque chose
que les marques mettent souvent en avant
c'était plus en plus le cas en 2020 ça
va continuer en 2021 sur l' usage vidéo
de smartphones est super en vidéo il
filme entendent images par seconde il
est super il errait super stabilisation
oui mais ce que derrière la qualité est
là est-ce que l'audio aussi est pas trop
mal
souvent c'est un peu le parent pauvre
mais c'est normal une fois de plus on
reste sur un smartphone donc ne tombez
pas dans le piège du très beau discours
marketing qui vous dit que la vidéo est
superbe
comparez regarder il fait vous même
votre propre opinion la question des
écrans est ce que oui sur un smartphone
l'écran c'est son regard le plus sauf si
vous aimez regarder d'autres votre
smartphone ou quelques as un petit peu
bizarre on regarde toujours ses écrans
bien évidemment et on achète souvent son
smartphone en disant même si je veux un
grand écran ou alors je veux pas un
petit écran qui va correspondre à la
taille de mes mains qui va correspondre
aux usages est ce que je le mets dans
une poche à ce qu'il dépasse ou pas dans
un sac et compagnie la question l'écran
est extrêmement importante et souvent on
regarde la taille et la taille ça peut
être trompeur vous allez pouvoir de très
beaux écrans qu'ils sont tout petits
et a contrario des très grands écrans
qui sont pas extraordinaires regardez la
technologie vous avez derrière
bien souvent on va retrouver des dalles
lcd mais qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver en
lcd vous avez dû ltps de pouvoir trouver
de lits ps lille ps sera mieux que le lt
ps paraît la question se pose entre le
oled et le
elle s'est dès que vous allez pouvoir
votre passion de très bons écrans lcd
extrêmement bien calibrée je vous prends
un exemple apple en 2019 avec son iphone
11 continuer à nous proposer un
smartphone avec un écran lcd sur
l'iphone 11 et uniquement sur l'iphone
cause c'était l'année dernière en 2001
avec son iphone et ce deuxième
génération l'iphone et ce 2020 eh bien
vous avez uniquement un écran lcd en hd
+ et même pas en full hd mais par contre
ce qui est assez bluffant là dessus
c'est qu'apple intègre vraiment bien
vous avez une superbe qualité de dalles
très bien calibrée très juste et le nom
connaissance dérape pas nécessairement
la différence entre cet écran lcd hd +
et un écran oled full hd plus des fois
voyait faut vraiment mettre en
perspective ce qui peut l'être
donc ne vous laissez pas berner
uniquement par une fiche technique une
fois de plus ne vous laissez pas berner
par une taille de l'écran sylvain du
local c'est un nul 5 6 ou le 7 pouces
posez vous la question derrière de la
technologie est ce que c'est bien
intégré oui ou non est ce que votre
écran vos sévir lutter contre la lumière
bleue pour éviter de s'abîmer les yeux
est-ce qu'il est lumineux ou non puisque
avoir un très grand écran et rien y voir
en plein jour ça peut aussi être un
petit peu dommage donc à tous ces points
à prendre en considération lorsque vous
allez regarder l'écran de votre
smartphone et croyez moi c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'on passe
beaucoup de temps sur son smartphone on
passe beaucoup de temps à regarder son
écran que ce soit pour naviguer ces
emails pour envoyer des messages pour
regarder des films des séries naviguer
sur les réseaux sociaux et que sais-je
encore donc penser à trouver une bonne
dalle qui va une fois de plus pouvoir
rentrer aussi dans votre budget une
erreur une erreur très importante ça ne
pas prendre en compte l'expérience
logiciels alors je sais c'est très
compliqué puisque il faudrait toutes les
essayer il faudrait tout pouvoir les
avoir à les comparer les unes devant les
autres mais d'une expérience logiciels à
l'autre des fois ne sais vraiment pas la
même chose
est ce que l'expérience est assez fluide
est ce qu'elle est claire et lisible at
aux accès facilement aux contenus
il ya beaucoup de points à venir
soulever quand on vient choisir son
smartphone pour savoir si l'expérience
logiciel derrière va être intéressant
parmi les meilleures expériences
logiciel qui existent aujourd'hui vous
allez pouvoir retrouver notamment ios
d'apple bien évidemment one way de
samsung également oxygène os domaine
plus qui marche très bien
il ya aussi coloré de peau qui est super
bien parce que très complet me wade
xiaomi qui a une très belle évolution
qui est aussi super sympa aujourd'hui
sans oublier l'expérience android pure
sur les smartphones de google certains
autres sont un peu moins bien
un peu en dessous il faut regarder une
fois de plus se renseigner pour voir ce
qui peut vraiment être intéressant pour
vous pour ne pas être déçu
il ya en même temps qu'elle on ne pense
jamais quand on vit à acheter son
smartphone c'est anticiper ses besoins
on l'achète en pensant à ce qu'on fait
un instant t alors des fois il faudrait
réussir à se projeter un peu plus loin
alors je sais que c'est compliqué mais
si vous achetez un smartphone vous
l'achetez pour minimum deux ans un peu
plus si vous pouvez ce serait vraiment
bien
une fois de plus pour éviter le
gaspillage et notamment au niveau du
stockage
pensez à ce que vous en faites
aujourd'hui est ce que vous en ferez
demain il m'est déjà arrivé par le passé
d'acheter un smartphone avec une
capacité de stockage trop réduite et
arrive un moment où je n'ai plus de
place pour stocker de nouvelles
applications de nouvelle photos donc
j'étais obligé de supprimer deux
applications pour l'installer une taille
à un moment ça ne va pas ça ne marche
pas donc en stockage pensait vraiment un
grand minimum de 64 giga de stockage pas
de seize patrons 2 si vous pouvez 128
c'est bien pour ne pas déchanter
rapidement
et puis le dernier point et non des
moindres c'est souvent de s'arrêter
qu'au design quand on n'y connaît rien
on va d'abord racheter aux smartphones
par rapport à l'image qu'ils renvoient
est-ce qu'il est beau est ce que je
trouve sympa est ce que je le verrais
bien dans ma poche et dans un an
alors ça c'est bien c'est un point
important mais ça ne doit pas masquer
tous les autres points que je vous ai
montré juste avant défend votre les
smartphones qui nous paraîtront très
beau mais qui derrière nous ne serons
pas ou au niveau de la photo avec un
écran pas complètement incroyable avec
une expérience logiciel qui est pas
dingue
le design effectivement est important
mais doit être moins important que tous
les autres points que vous ai cités
précédemment
vous voilà maintenant avertis vous ne
ferez donc plus ses erreurs lorsque vous
allez dire achetez votre prochain
smartphone alors maintenant je vais vous
donner quelques conseils lorsque vous
allez venir acheter votre smartphone
c'est une nouveauté 2021 c'est l' indice
de réparabilité est ce que votre
smartphone va être facile à réparer
s'il lui arrive le moins de problèmes
oui ou non regardez le les constructeurs
aujourd'hui en france en tout cas sont
obligés de vous donner si vous n'êtes
pas en france allez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil sur les sites français ça vous
permettra de vous faire une idée par
rapport à lundi de réparabilité de
smartphones vous avez aussi la question
de la garantie
si vous avez acheté par exemple
smartphone auprès d'un particulier
eh bien vous n'aurez pas de garantie
aucune si vous étiez de smartphones
d'occasion sur un site de reconditionner
dire vous aurez une garantie regardez en
fonction de la plateforme garantie 3
mois une garantie de 1 an vous en
trouverez ça c'est aussi un pack
extrêmement intéressant puis la garantie
en neuf
lorsque vous êtes en tout cas
aujourd'hui en france david est garanti
2 ans pano garantie constructeur et la
deuxième c'est la garantie européenne
comme ça moi vous êtes tranquille et
protégés il ya un paquet pour moi va
être extrêmement important pour venir
vous
l'idée leur vos achats en ligne
consulter la presse spécialisée regarder
des chaînes youtube comme la graine par
exemple d'ailleurs plus penser à venir
vous abonner regard des différents
médias en ligne consultez lisez comparer
prenez un petit peu de temps pour amant
vous faire votre propre idée basée sur
des avis de professionnels qui ont
l'habitude de tester des smartphones ça
je vous le dis aujourd'hui pour les
smartphones mais ça peut être également
pour n'importe quel achat que ce soit
une tabelle que ce soit une voiture lave
linge enfin bref vous avez compris un
peu l'histoire
alors ya une petite astuce je sais que
c'est les vendeurs de e-commerce nous
offre la tête mais des fois mieux vaut
acheter en ligne comme ça si le
smartphone ne vous plaît pas sous 14
jours vous pouvez leur envoyer et vous
faire rembourser ça vous coûtera juste
les frais de retour les frais
d'expédition retour mais ça peut vous
éviter des déconvenues sur le long terme
une fois vous ai trouvé un smartphone
qui vous plaît regardez ce qui est
disponible reconditionnés pour l'acheter
un peu moins cher ça sera bon pour votre
portefeuille ce sera bon pour la planète
ça permettra des smartphones de vivre et
d'exister un peu plus longtemps
au lieu d'être jetés et recycler
directement à vous de me dire vous ce
que vous pensez de ces quelques conseils
astuces et de ces points que j'ai
soulevé ici dans cette vidéo
est-ce que vous avez vous aussi des
astuces à dire partager si oui marqué
des mois en bas en commentaire on
partage on argumente on discute ça s'est
vraiment bien sur ce je vous embrasse
moi monde beaucoup d'impôts rendez vous
très vite des choeurs du lot et à très
bientôt
ciao